What’s good padna? This week we
breakin’ dem chains with Beloved by
Toni Morrison.
Somethin creepy goin down up at da
crib called “124,” where a hardass
mama named Sethe livin’ wit her
daughter Denver. Apparently, da
spot haunted by Sethe’s dead baby
girl who ridin’ Sethe and Denver so
hard dat they too scurred to leave
da house.
And 124 ain’t da only place dat’s
kept Sethe locked up. See back in
the day, Sethe was a slave at some
hell-hole plantation called “Sweet
Home” where she went through some
of da most dehumanizin’ sh** yo
bitch-ass can imagine. Eventually
she was able to escape dat trap and
head to Cincinatti. But even tho
she free physically, she still
chained up by all dem horrible
memories.
One night some G Sethe knew from
back at Sweet Home named Paul D
drop in at 124. Denver ain’t so
happy to see him, but sethe SHO AS
HELL IS. Cuz not 5 minutes afta’
seein him, Sethe’s panties on the
flo and they gettin buck nasty on
da reg. Paul must be givin her the
D REAL good, cuz afta’ dat, it’s
like the ghost ain’t doggin 124 no
mo. And afta’ a while, even Denver
start warmin up to this playa.
But the good times don’t last, son.
Outta nowhere, some fly lil hunny
callin herself Beloved show up
lookin ill. Sethe take her in, but
there definitely somethin off bout
this dip.
Life was gettin’ pretty sweet with
Paul and his D in tha house, but
now wit Beloved there, errything
start fallin to sh**. Somethin’
bout Beloved bein there forces Paul
otta da crib and he start livin’ in
da cold house. One night, tho,
Beloved roll up on dat shack and
warm dat cold house UP. Naw I’m
sayin?? Sex... But fo’ some reason,
Pauly can’t enjoy Beloved booty
dancing on his junk; instead his
mind filled with a buncha horrible
memories from Sweet Home. Weird.
Afta Paul and Beloved do tha nasty,
Beloved start pushin her weight up
in 124 like she own da place and
erryone in it.
Then one day, some homie named
Stamp Paid all like “Pauly, you
ain’t know why Sethe and Denver
neva’ leave tha crib?” Apparently,
things were all good in da hood fo’
Sethe and da fam afta escapin from
Sweet Home. But one day, when Sethe
hear her old slavemaster closin in
on her new digs, she straight SNAP
and say “I’d rather KILL my babies
then let dat fool put em in
chains!” And girl wasn’t playin,
cuz she takes all her kids to tha
shed ready to merc erry one of em.
The only one she actually kill is a
baby girl who she later name
Beloved... which make this whole
house guest thing pretty damn
creepy, amirite?
Paul cain’t believe what he hearin,
so he jus grab his sh** and bounce.
Wit dat big-balla gone, it’s like
Beloved blowin up while Sethe keep
shrinkin’. When Denver see how bad
Beloved mistreating her mama, she
decide she gonna keep it real, get
her house outta da house, and do
somethin to make dat bitch LEAVE.
Afta’ Denver hit up a buncha black
folk around town, a whole posse
crew up to get Beloved outta dat
house. Errybody start singin, and
things lookin good; dat is, until
some white dude roll up on the
house. He jus’ tryna give Denver a
job but Sethe thinkin it her old
slavemaster. So she goes APE, grabs
an icepick and tries to ice dis
fool. Damn girl. Denver and the
posse have to take her down, and
Beloved hits da road.
Now dat B-lo’s gone, Denver’s knows
who she is AND got da joose to get
herelf outta da house. Paul D stop
actin a fool and come back to tha
124 to build a life with Sethe.
Errybody who spent they life in
chains is finally one step closer
to bein’ free.
Now you might be thinkin: Wassup
wit dat girl Beloved? Is she really
Sethe’s zombified daughter back
from the dead? Is she some creeper
pretendin to be a dead baby?
Sumethin else? Scholars got all
kinda dank theories bout B-lo; cuz
truth is, who or what she be ain’t
so clear cut, sucka.
My favorite way of thinkin bout it
is that it ain’t bout Beloved bein
a ghost or a person- what’s
important is dat she a symbol,
reppin all da horrible sh** black
folk had to tussle wit over da
years: ‘specially da memories of
pain, death, and torture durin’
slave times. See, when Beloved drop
in at 124, she bring back all dem
buried horrors of Paul and Sethe’s
time up at Sweet Home.
And to make things worse, Beloved
don’t jus make you think bout da
past- she make you relive it right
here right now. Paul D always
talkin bout how he didn’t even feel
like a person back at sweet home,
sayin bum sh** like:
Sparky reads quote: “I was something else
and that something
else was less than a chicken sitting in the
sun on a tub.”
And if you thinkin that ain’t
nothin’ gonna make him feel more
like a man that a piece of
Beloved’s fine ass, you be trippin,
yo. After crackin off a piece of
summodat hoochie coochie:
“Paul D had come to be a rag doll- picked
up and put back
down anywhere any time by a girl young enough
to be his
daughter. fu**ing her when he was convinced
he didn’t want
to...humiliated... ad yet there was nothing
he could do about
it.”
Po’ Sethe in da same depressingass,
rememory-filled boat. Sethe
get so amped up on hatred for dem
racist slavers, and so full of love
and regret fo’ ghosting her own
baby-girl, dat she start actin’
like she ain’t even good ‘nuff fo’
forgiveness. Damn girl, show
yo’self a lil’ love.
Maybe da reason it’s so damn hard
to figure out who or what Beloved
be is cuz she a different thing to
all da books’ major playas. To paul
D, she a mystery and a lover; to
Sethe, she a daughter, and a
reminder of ol’ pains;
to Denver, she a sistah, and a hope
dat she won’t eva’ be alone.
Then again, maybe the real clue why
Beloved seem different to errybody
is in her name: Love. Love look
different to errybody. To some, it
can breathe life in to yo daily
grind
like nuthin else. But to
others, it can fu** sh** up like
you ain’t even know.
So let me show you what love looks like
to this thug: This here subscribe
button. So hit it and catch me lata. Peace!